well certainly a lot of the challenges
that we've been experiencing this year
will continue into next year but there
are both short-term and long-term steps
that we can take to do something about
it look part of what's happening isn't
just the supply side it's the demand
side demand is up because income is up
because the president has successfully
guided this economy out of the teeth of
a terrifying recession meanwhile
americans are getting crushed by bite
inflation as we get closer to the
holidays one in five americans already
started their holiday shopping last
month all right dana so we have empty
shelves high inflation soaring gas
prices labor shortages high crime and a
migration crisis and in this country and
probably any other country if you just
have maybe three of those things that's
a political crisis biden has all of them
and but you can trace all of those
issues back are there are policy
decisions and policy decisions that have
consequences and so
you have all of those things happening
especially when you overstimulate the
economy and you saw just last week over
50 percent of people
pulled by gallup said
we don't want government to get any
bigger we don't think we need any of
this extra money like they realize that
what happens is if you have a situation
where you have increased demand not
enough supply wait it's going to happen
this is exactly what's going to happen
um the other thing is is that mayor pete
has been quite indignant right he's
frustrated that people say that maybe he
shouldn't have been on paternity leave
i'm fine take your paternity leave but
if you take leave that means that
somebody fills in for your job like and
i looked it up and there is a deputy
transportation secretary her name is
paulie trottenberg
and i don't remember seeing her out
there either i feel like all of these
issues seem to come at them late because
they're really focused on trying to pass
things like the human infrastructure
bill and then they forget that all of
these other things are happening when i
took my paternity leave
i was only gone for a couple days and
someone took my place here at the table
what do i just said what they call it
the four
the entire paternity that's not how it
works
it is this is a great test for
government if no one notices a loss of
services or that you're not there maybe
get rid of him maybe he should be fired
if no one cared even the fact that no
one in the media did a welfare check we
haven't seen the transportation
secretary since then
peter are you okay are you okay showed
up i'm bottle feeding i'm gonna start
using the excuse of bottle feeding
because technically i am feeding myself
but look as a person pete is right to
take off that time if it's available but
as a leader he's an embarrassment no
leader in a time of crisis would take
two months off even professional
athletes don't do that they take off a
few games here and there but i mean you
know you got to come to work when
there's something going on but the chaos
with this the whole cargo thing
his experience is the perfect metaphor
it didn't it didn't disturb his
lifestyle
he is an elite who was able to take the
eight weeks off because it didn't hammer
him it hammers the middle class and it's
gonna hammer the working class but
somebody like him well educated got a
great job in government you know he can
he can weather it there's just something
weird about a mayor of a city
of a city that was in so much trouble
like cleveland that he decided instead
of sticking to the job and fixing things
he ran for president so that makes you
smart but it makes you a terrible leader
that's what we're finding out he
abandoned the city the city of twinkly
lights
pointing to joe biden south bend
my favorite richard he says our supply
chains can't keep up well where did he
and all his mckinsey guys put the supply
chains in china
they can't keep up because they're
halfway around the world i don't think
he put the supply chain
mckinsey advised the politicians along
with the fortune 500 companies put them
in china you avoid regulations taxes and
you have to pay your workers less
there's nothing more that i want than to
all of our for all of our supply chains
here in the united states the reality is
is that you know and i will also grant
you that i think the biden
administration was a little bit slow to
the mic in addressing how we deal with
the supply chain issue but it's worth
pointing out that the
supply chain issues that we have are far
bigger than joe biden and they're far
bigger than the white house we have a
global support
we're dealing with a global supply chain
issue if you're paying attention to the
global news what you'll find out is that
last week in the united kingdom they ran
out of fuel right because they have a
supply chain issue happening there yeah
so and the supply chain issue happened
because it started in 2000 when chinese
factories shut down because of kova 19.
and when they and we had orders in china
that were two months behind and then
when china started sending their
products to the united states our port
shut down because we had caught we had
cover 19 and we had social distancing
issues so now what we're dealing with is
a relay race that is about 100 yards
back and we're trying to catch up so yes
you're right the biden administration
was slow to the past to say america
here's what we're dealing with here's
why this down is happening like you said
at the beginning of the set this the
segment right we have a labor shortage
it's happening with truckers it's
happening with longshoremen which is
also impacting which has downward
pressure on what's actually happening
right now so the american people are
seeing empty shelves they're waiting
three and four months to get their sofas
to get their their mini coopers their
mini coopers to get their their iphone
13s but the result of it is a globalized
problem that is a result of the fact
that we just dealt with a global
pandemic that affected the whole world
in which we shut the the light switch
off of the entire global economy why was
that because of government policy
because millions of americans died
that's why it was
millions of people around the world
to stop production to implement
restrictions that didn't allow people to
get back to work and held on to those
restrictions for far too long because of
some political motive like with gavin
newsom in california back to be
buddhadej uh when he was running for
president there you know people in the
primary democratic primary were saying
look he can't even fix potholes uh in
south bend why are we going to not only
elect him as president but he's going to
be joe biden's transportation secretary
peter judge was on paternity leave
says he didn't have time to appoint
someone to take over his job was off the
clock he had plenty of time to
participate in a documentary he had
plenty of time to do an interview with
people magazine about his new life so
it's just a matter of prioritizing his
fame and wanting to pull a fouchy on
being being on the cover of magazines
versus dealing with real problems that
america is having right now with the
supply chain final thing i'll say is now
that the ports are backed up in
california they need people to offload
what's in the port and they need drivers
that's a shortage of workers well
california labor law through
ab5 doesn't allow that because you can't
hire gig workers the pro act which is in
the infrastructure bill that joe biden
wants to pass does the same thing on a
national level every single person you
hire has to be a full-time employee with
full benefits and they do that because
they want the unions for political
capital and so this problem's not
getting fixed on a policy uh level
anytime soon whether it's through the
bite administration or through
california politics either so what i
hear you saying katie it's the democrats
fault that what you're saying yes okay
that's what i heard yeah
and by the way richard the reason
they're having fuel shortages in europe
is because putin's playing energy
politics oh actually it's because they
have a truck walker's there that's why
mobile news coming up hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else